welcome to my video series of mall bio
explained in three minutes where I
explain a concept of mall buy in less
than three minutes or so it is not a
detailed explanation but it has all the
necessary information to save your ass
before the day of your exam if you
haven't yet subscribed to my channel
please hit that subscribe button and in
this installment we'll talk about how n
labeling of the DNA is achieved
sometimes we really need radiolabeled
DNA to perform in situ hybridization or
South and bloating so southern blotting
or in situ hybridization in order to
detect the our nuclear nucleic acid of
interest we need a radio labeled or some
label true and in order to label that
either radiologically or by any other
non radial label probe we can use this
technique that I'm going to describe in
this video so here is our DNA region of
interest which we are going to detect so
we can generate the probe from this
region of the DNA itself right and first
what we use is alkaline phosphatase
alkaline phosphatase would cleave off
the terminal Phi prime phosphate group
and make a hydroxyl group instead now
this hydroxyl group can be used to
attach several other nucleotides at the
end so that is done by poly nucleotide
kinase now poly nucleotide kinase can
attach new nucleotides at the end and in
the five prime end we can use a radio
level 2 nucleotide to label that most of
the cases the radio label which is
incorporating the 5 prime end is no is
gamma 32 ADP or something like that or
some time sulfur is also used as a radio
level so this however it is the gamma
phosphate is incorporated into the label
and thereby a terminal end of the DNA
gets radiologically labeled now that is
how we achieve radio labeling offered
DNA segments now there are other
variants of this technique which
labels the DNA at three prime end it is
called three prime n leveling which we
would be talking about in other videos
and also there is sparse labeling method
using Nick translation which we would
talk in other videos as well so if you
like this video and it is helpful give
it a quick thumbs up and don't forget to
Like share and subscribe thank you